okay then I have a bit of a strange
question for you you know the way
football players have like a signature
pose they do after they have a goal the
way Belling him hold his arms out if you
had to have one after like a Checkmate
finesse what do you think you would
do I like the Bellingham post maybe I'll
I'll copy that and uh we know you play a
lot of online Blitz you recently got the
highest uh rating on chess.com 3340 but
how much over theboard Blitz do you
actually play uh I very rarely play over
theboard Blitz um yeah uh there are very
good players who live in the ow area
like uh David how ariari hammer and
sometimes Johan Sebastian is there as
well but but um yeah somehow we don't
really we don't really play